what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
taking a deeper look into Dec whose
childhood doctor and his nefarious role
in the boku no hero story about a year
and a half ago I made a video about dec
whose doctor and in that video I
presented a theory that Dec whose doctor
might actually be a villain who works
for all for one since that time a lot
has happened in the manga and we have
gotten a lot more shocking information
about this doctor actually saw quite a
few comments asking me for an updated
video about the doctor based on the huge
manga developments I definitely read the
comments and I appreciate your feedback
so in this video I will be doing exactly
that I will break down everything we
know so far about this mysterious doctor
and I will explain why he could be an
even more devious and sinister figure
than it appears at first glance if you
enjoyed the boku no hero content here on
the channel and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications the way that
YouTube works now if you don't go
through the trouble of hitting the bell
and selecting the option for all
notifications you're gonna miss a lot of
our videos you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest boku no hero news and
updates as I already mentioned this
video is updating everything we know so
far about the doctor including manga
stuff that wasn't covered in the anime
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned so before the latest
developments in the manga and the
shocking confirmation of the theory that
this doctor is indeed a villain and all
for one's personal doctor
we knew that back when Deku was a kid
his quirk failed to materialize his mom
got worried and she took him to see the
doctor
and this doctor whose surname is
apparently Tsubasa according to the
official ma che character book went on
to explain to deco and his mother that
Deku has two joints on his pinkie toe
the second joint on his pinkie toe has
become unnecessary for humans because
they no longer need to
use it and the people who are born
without the extra joint are considered
to be the next stage of human evolution
there are also the people who have gone
on to manifest quirks but apparently the
people who still have that second joint
on the pinky toe will never have a quirk
and this includes deku I say apparently
because as we know now this doctor is
not a very trustworthy medical
professional it turns out that this
doctor who first appeared in chapter 1
is the same doctor who appears later on
in the story as the personal doctor of
the arch-villain all-for-one we first
see a glimpse of him in chapter 59 and
then much later our suspicions are
finally confirmed in chapters 220 and
221 of the manga that being said even
before chapter 220 there were other
subtle clues that Dec whose childhood
doctor and all for once doctor were the
same person including the fact that once
they appear in the anime both the
childhood doctor and the villain doctor
have the exact same voice actor in both
English and Japanese the revelation that
all for once doctor and dec who's called
her doctor are the same person
sparked a ton of interesting fan
theories one of these theories is that
Deku may have been born with a quirk but
the doctor stole his quirk in order to
give it to all for one and then lied to
Deku maybe even showed him a fake x-ray
in order to make Deku think that he
never had a quirk in the first place
another theory is that this doctor turns
the children that he treats in his
medical practice into the nomal
artificial humans according to the
character book this doctor shares the
same surname tsubasa as the boy with
wings who used to hang out with baku go
back when Baku and Deku were still just
kids in fact the doctor is apparently
this boy's grandfather and in the past
horikoshi used sketches to hint at the
fact that the winged boy is directly
connected to the winged nomu who would
go on to grab deck who during the
stained arc this led many to speculate
that the doctor is turning children into
normal
that he even turned his own grandson
into the wind nomu and while this is
definitely possible it is not yet
confirmed so I don't want to jump the
gun because there are other
possibilities as well and I will get to
those possibilities later on in this
video when he introduces himself to
shigaraki and the rest of the league of
villains the doctor uses the alias
Daruma Fujiko at this point we realized
that the person who has been using that
gross sludge teleportation quirk in
order to help over one in the past has
been the doctor himself he is
Fujiko when he finally meets with
shigaraki face-to-face the doctor
expressed his disappointment in him
explaining that all for one designated
shigaraki as his successor but shigaraki
has not done anything that would justify
all for once confidence it is also
important to note that once the league
meets the doctor inside his lair they
noticed that many high and nomu are
located inside his laboratory however
the doctor explains that none of these
normal are ready for testing and he
cannot finalize the production of more
high and normal without the help of all
for one and of course we know that all
for one is currently indisposed as he is
incarcerated inside the super
maximum-security Tartarus prison
according to the my hero academia
official character book - in his day job
as a doctor Yuji ko or Tsubasa however
you want to call him apparently runs
multiple orphanages and clinics knowing
what we know now about what you jiggle
does in his spare time it is likely that
he uses the children in his orphanages
and clinics for some type of normal
experimentation he may steal the
children's quirks he may do placate
their quirks or he may even turn the
children into nomu themselves now that
would be a pretty damn dark and tragic
twist if true turning innocent children
into mindless beasts of destruction we
are not sure what exactly would you Co
is doing with the children in his care
because there are several ways that
Lucas quirk research could operate he
could be using all for one's quirk to
outright steal other people's quirks
just like all for once told the quirk of
the hero rag doll he could also be
turning the children into no mo and
giving them multiple
works at once with the help of all-4-one
or he could be somehow duplicating the
quirks of the children and then giving
the duplicate quirk to the normal while
still allowing the original owner of the
quirk to keep using it the original
owner may not even be aware that their
quirk was duplicated in the past i
theorize that Fujiko might be
duplicating quirks back when I read
chapter 185 the high-end nomu known as
hood appeared to possess the exact same
muscle augmentation quirk as the villain
muscular along with several other quirks
since we know that back when muscular
was arrested and sent to Tartarus prison
he still had his quirk it doesn't appear
that Yuko would have had the opportunity
to steal it therefore it is possible
that at some point before muscular was
arrested Fujiko was able to somehow copy
his quirk and then give it to the high
and normal while still allowing muscular
to keep his own quirk but now you may be
wondering if this doctor can just
duplicate the quirks of villains then
what's with his interest in children
isn't experimenting on children and
potentially even turning them into
normal unnecessarily cruel even for a
villain there are so many adults out
there that he could be using for his
experiments instead of innocent children
but there is actually a reason why
Yuko is interested in children in
particular and that reason has to do
with quirk singularity we've gotten
hints about this before but in Chapter
two four six we learned that ug Co
ascribes to the school of thought known
as the quirk singularity in fact Fujiko
claims that he came up with the entire
concept in the first place quirk
singularity refers to the idea that as
new generations of quark users are born
the quirks that the children are born
with are becoming stronger and stronger
with each passing generation as
different powerful quirks mixed together
to create even more powerful quirks we
will eventually get to a point at which
the quirks that the user manifests will
be too strong for him and her to control
as Foucault puts it the memory will
exceed the hardware meaning that the
power of the quark will exceed the
capabilities of the quirks users body
according to logical this has already
been happening since the fourth
generation
quirk users and a great example of this
quirk singularity phenomenon is of
course Airy at a very young age she
manifested an incredibly powerful quirk
rewind but she was unable to control it
and as a result she accidentally rewound
her own father out of existence
Fujiko believes that as more and more
quirks continue to mix this type of
phenomenon will become increasingly
common and eventually chaos will ensue
and that brings us back to why Yuko
would be specifically targeting the
quirks of children if we accept the
logic of the quirk singularity concept
that it stands to reason that children
the newest generation will have the
strongest and most advanced quirks
so if Fujiko is going to steal or copy
quirks so that he can later use them for
the gnome or give them to all from one
it makes perfect sense for him to go
after the quirk so children that is how
a young Deku ended up visiting the same
doctor who just happened to be the
personal doctor of all for one it was no
coincidence that said there is no
evidence the Deku had a quirk which was
stolen by Uchiko
without Deku realizing it it is possible
that deck who really didn't have a quirk
and logical was telling the truth
but it isn't impossible that a
manipulator like would Yuko could have
lied to Deku while secretly stealing his
quirk and using a doctored x-ray to
cover his tracks
get it doctored anyway we know that uh
booty Co has always been extremely
careful to keep his identity a secret
and to keep his normal related research
hidden from the outside world after all
for one is arrested Fujiko is very
hesitant to embrace shigaraki and the
rest of the league of villains even
though all for once specifically
designated shigaraki as his direct
successor
Fujiko is extremely wary of shigar aki
and the league at first and he makes the
league prove themselves as worthy before
he agrees to help them once she Guara ki
does prove himself and unlocks the true
potential of his decay quark
Fujiko agrees to perform an operation on
shigaraki that is going to make him
stronger than ever before apparently
after this operation shigaraki will be
able to handle even more power than all
for one and he will become capable of
doing what all-4-one never could and
that is stealing and absorbing one for
all i am assuming that this operation
will somehow
creased Shiga Rocky's body's memory as
Foucault likes to put it basically his
body or hardware will become strong
enough to handle more memory or more
quirks and more power nevertheless
Fujiko warns shigaraki that although
extremely effective this operation will
also cause tremendous pain and agony for
shigaraki the process will take four
months and during those four months
shigaraki will be exposed to torturous
conditions including horrible pain in
spite of that
Shigure aki agrees that he will proceed
with the operation and as of the making
this video the last time we saw you gqo
he was beginning his work on shigaraki
procedure overall it is clear that Yuko
is a medical and scientific genius who
was able to treat all for one and save
him from the brink of death while also
successfully creating incredibly
powerful artificial humans known as the
normal what's more the new high end
normal are a drastic improvement over
the previous models which means that you
giucose research is progressing rapidly
and he is becoming more and more
dangerous by the day we don't know what
ug COEs quirk is provided that he has
one because we have never actually seen
him use it however we do know that you
Chico is extremely loyal to all from one
that he is dedicated to his research and
that he doesn't hesitate to do immoral
or even outright evil things if he feels
that this will benefit the cause of his
research it is unclear what exactly Yugi
cause motivations are although his life
offers us some important clues for why
he is doing the things he is doing
perhaps Yugi ko is just loyal to
all-4-one and he will do anything to
make his boss happy including kidnapping
children experimenting on innocent
people and destroying the entire hero
society but I suspect that there is more
to UCO's motivations than just that we
know that Hugo was apparently the first
person to bring up the concept of quirk
singularity but no one took him
seriously except for all for one I think
that og goes true motivations may be
directly connected to his quirk
singularity theory if you gqo really
believes that quirk singularity is a
serious problem
then he must believe that if things stay
as they are then all of society will
eventually collapse since no one is
taking his idea seriously no one else is
going to take
to protect society from the chaos of
quirk singularity so in a few years or
in a few generations quirks are going to
manifest that are unbelievably powerful
and impossible to control this could
cause mass destruction carnage and death
on a global scale and no one is taking
any steps to prevent it no one except
for ug co based on the operation that he
is currently performing on shigaraki we
know that you Chico has figured out a
way to make the hardware capable of
handling more memory in other words he
is able to create bodies that can handle
more powerful quirks he has gained this
knowledge by conducting cruel and
immoral experiments on children
civilians and the normal but he is
probably doing all of this because he
feels that these experiments and this
research are the only way to stop quirk
singularity from one day destroying
everything and everyone on the planet
would Yuko likely thinks that what he is
doing right now is his duty he is the
only one who takes quark singularity
seriously and he is the only one who can
save the world from mass destruction if
he can find a way to negate the effects
of quark singularity and he intends to
do this by modifying the bodies of
people in order to allow them to control
even the unbelievably powerful next gen
quirks of the future
Fujiko probably feels that all of the
immoral things that he is doing are
necessary for the greater good of
stopping quark singularity after all
what are a few dozen or even a few
hundred innocent victims if the survival
of all of humanity is at stake if you
gqo believes that his experiments are
the only thing that can save humans from
quark singularity then it becomes easier
to see how a mad scientist like him
might have concluded that the ends
justify the means and that his cruel
experiments are justified because they
are the only way to prevent the
destruction of all of humanity we don't
know for sure what would you cause true
intentions and motivations are but this
idea of quark singularity and the goal
of modifying bodies in order to make
them capable of handling more power is
definitely my best guess at this point
in time but let me know what you guys
think
why did Dec whose childhood dr. become a
villain and what are his true
motivations also do you think that the
doctor secretly stole deck was real
quark without Deku even realizing it or
was Deku really quark less the hole
time definitely share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more boku no
hero content right here on the channel
please leave a like it really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime out pro
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to all of our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King's eldest on hell
cruise stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat karate
Gian Anatole Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget the ones
that rise above all other clans a
massive thank you to all of our the one
tier patrons including in grata alone
Adam Maddie Mac makoto-kun and you boys
Seth if you enjoy our videos and you
think that they add some value to your
life consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our page and exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]